الدواء من الداء طفل يخضع لعقوبه غريبه من
والده بسبب العاب الفيديو
الان شاهد طفله وهو يلعب العاب الفيديو
على هاتفه بعد منتصف الليل رغم انه كان
عليه الاستيقاظ للمدرسه مبكرا في صباح
اليوم التالي واراد الاب ان يعلم الصبيه
درسا لن ينساه بسهوله فبدلا من توبيخ
الصبيع عقبه بطريقه غريبه واجبره على
متابعه اللعب بدلا من النوم
[موسيقى]
استمتع الطفل بعقوبته غير المعتاده قليلا
في البدايه واستمر في اللعب على هاتفه تحت
اشراف والده طوال الليل حتى حوالي الساعه
السابعه صباحا وعندما بدات طفل في النعاس
حاول ترك الهاتف والنوم لكن لم يسمح له
والده واستمر في ايقاذه ليكمل اللعب دون
نوم
وما كان من الصبي سوى ان يعد بانه لن يلعب
مره اخرى على هاتفه دون علم والديه حتى
انه وافق على وضع وعد كتابيا لجعل ذلك
رسميا
الفيديو الذي نشره الاب اثار مؤخرا نقاشا
ساخنا حول الطريقه التي يتم التعامل بها
في مثل هذه الحالات اشاد البعض بالاب على
التفكير خارج الصندوق واجعل الصبي يمرض من
هوايته المفضله بينما انتقده اخرون
لاجباره على البقاء مستيقظا لفتره طويله
في عمر لا يزال دماغه في طور النمو
[موسيقى]
ومن المثير للاهتمام ان هذه الطريقه في
معاقبه الاطفال تجعلهم يفعلون الاشياء
التي يحبونها حتى يصبحوا لا يطيقونها تبدو
شائعه في الصين
[موسيقى]